so let's do one of these stories that will
probably get everybody upset or disagreeing
in some way, shape, or form.
Over the weekend.
Some of the democratic candidates did interviews
with Pelham window, the Spanish
language channel, and the interviewer, whose
name is Guadalupe Vegas of course, talked
about many issues including Mexico.
And when the of Mexico came up, he would start
to ask the candidates what they knew about
the Mexican president, Obadiah adored, and
both Amy Klobuchar and Tom Stier didn't seem
to know that much and eventually got to the
question of, do you know the president's name
in Mexico?
And neither was able to say the Mexican president's
name appearing not to know them.
And Klobuchar is a case and maybe to have
forgotten it in Tom Steyer's case.
So let's check out the clips.
First one here is Amy Klobuchar.
You can see Amy Klobuchar is widely known.
Disdain for her staff, noticeable when it
becomes clear that she is going to be or has
been when she's asked the president's name,
she looks off camera to someone, presumably
a staffer with that well known.
How did you allow this to happen?
Sort of look, here's Amy Klobuchar.
Yes.
Uh, what do you know about the Mexican president?
Okay, well, what I will tell you is that I
will visit Mexico in the first a 100 years,
but 100 100 days, a hundred days, uh, there
are running for president.
You would like to be the, uh, democratic candidate.
Yeah.
What do you know about the Mexican president
now?
Well, I know that he is, uh, an elected in
the last few years.
I don't know him personally.
I've met with the ambassador and I was actually
supportive of the trade agreement, so I worked
with the embassy on that.
They came to meet with me and I asked because
it's so important, especially Nevada, California,
Arizona, Texas is our neighbor to itself.
Yeah.
Do you know anything about him specifically
his politics, what he's doing since this would
be the country you would share a border with.
You can tell me about him.
I just, I know that they are neighbors and
regardless of who the leader is that it is
someone that I will work with you.
I'm sorry to ask this, but do you know who
he is?
Do you know his name?
I um, I know that he is the Mexican president,
but can you tell me his name?
I know, don't you think it would be important
if you're running for president to know who
the president of Mexico, the country to the
South of the United States is because it affects
so many Americans.
Okay.
That was Amy Klobuchar.
And then here's Tom Stier also asked the same
question.
Do you know about his policies?
He's a very, he's a very progressive man.
I'm asking because I feel like a lot of the
times this is our neighbor to the South and
a lot of people don't even know his name.
So you know, I forgot his name, I forget,
but I'm just saying, I followed this policy.
I'm sorry.
We are Telemundo and our viewers are Hispanic
speakers.
And you're running for, you want the candidacy
to represent the Democrats, but you can't
tell me the president of Mexico.
You don't know who the president of Mexico
followed this look.
I followed this election.
I've watched what's happened.
Important to know who the neighbor to the
cell phones do.
But let me say this, I followed this election
from the standpoint of he was, he was the
mayor of Mexico city.
He's a progressive man.
I followed this policy from the standpoint,
what does this mean
for him getting along with us?
What does it mean for him getting along with
a right wing nationalist president in the
United States of America, and how are we going
to relate to that?
And so to me, I followed that very closely
because there's a real question in Mexico,
where are they going with their policies?
This was a true change.
It was a distinct change.
It's not so have I met him?
No.
Have I, do I go to Mexico every single year?
Yes.
Do I understand that Mexico is at a crossroads
in terms of how it is governed and this was
a distinct choice that scared the pants off
people off business people in Mexico, in the
United States?
Yes, I do.
So there are basically three stories here
to talk about.
The first is the top level.
Wow.
They don't know the Mexican president's name.
Now it's true that not knowing the Mexican
president's name is very different than not
knowing the name of the president of Slovakia.
For example, who I looked up the name, it's
Susanna Kapito VA because our relationship
with Mexico is very different than our relationship,
uh, to Slovakia.
Our proximity, the number of people who come
to the United States from Mexico is much greater
than Slovakia.
So it's not the same.
But at any point you can do a sort of, do
you know the name ofX leader question?
And maybe the person does or maybe the person
doesn't.
But with most politicians, you would find
someone whose name they don't know and you
can make them not look very good in the moment.
I am actually more concerned with what the
candidates know about the Mexican president
and his policy and us Mexico relations.
Then whether they know the name, although
not knowing the name is a concern.
So neither Klobuchar nor Tom Stire remembered
open others name Stier later said, well I
know him, but I just forgot the name.
All Clover Klobuchar was able to say was he
was recently a NEC elected.
She genuinely seemed to have no idea about
anything else.
And she's a sitting us Senator Tom Star's
a businessman.
He says he did know the name but he forgot
it, but he was at least able to list some
of the background in the prior positions of,
uh, the, the current Mexican president.
So even though they both forgot his name,
my reaction is less negative to Stire based
on the totality of what was said than Klobuchar.
Even though the headlines simplified it as
Amiens Stier, neither can name the Mexican
president.
I care far less about remembering his name
than about how they understand relations with
Mexico, what they would do about immigration,
the war on drugs, economic policy to support
Mexico trade where Amy Klobuchar voted in
favor of Trump's trade deal.
Tom Stier, I think from what I've seen him
say, would not have where he in a position
to do.
So all of that and forgetting or not knowing
the name, it's something but not all that
much.
When Gary Johnson was asked about Aleppo and
he said, what is Aleppo not even recognizing
that it is a city?
Uh, that's very different, right?
Not realizing that Aleppo is a city that's
central to what's happening in Syria.
That's not this.
Now, lastly, you have to understand that these
clips are being used by some cynical mayor
Pete supporters.
Pete was asked and did know the Mexican president's
name, and there's all these side by sides
now going around where Pete names the president
and Amy and Stier cat.
I mean, okay.
Maybe that's how some people decide who to
vote for.
I hope we're making a deeper analysis than
who you can name.
So is this cartoony and funny and quirky in
some way?
Yes it is, but there's actually a much deeper
issue here to talk about and that's about
policy.
When it comes
to Mexico,